round two of the Sinquefield cup the  premier chess tournament in the world it  was a day full of tension as the best  players on the planet bought some  contentious games in a bid for all-out  victory  Fabiano Khurana missed an easy win and  moved 40 against Levon Aronian and had  to work for another 70 moves before  finally grinding down his opponents to  leap into a tie for first I would play  150 moves if it meant I win again in a  rematch of World Championship rivals  Magnus Carlsen took control of the game  against Sergey Karjakin and finish off  the position with some deaf strokes to  join two other players atop the  leaderboard at that point I'm firmly  taking the initiative so it should have  done something different it's been a  tournament full of decisive games round  reaction live from st. Louis coming up  next  [Music]